welcome back
shut up
were they beaten with a whip to make
mint chocolate chip
yeah that's funny huh
it is funny kids getting beaten kids
getting beaten that's great Emily so how
can you enjoy the new flavors from these
child enslavers
all right you're the best New York Times
X and New York Times expose eight
reveals how revered American companies
such as Ben Jerry's use migrant child
labor to make their products
wow no wonder it's so delicious Emily
of course the hypocrisy is too good Ben
and Jerry's a self-described progressive
company has been Infamous for spreading
woke virtues like it was salmonella and
by giving their flavors silly left-wing
names so you can really taste the social
activism flavors like pecan resist pecan
yeah sent a message of resistance to
Donald Trump and then there was
empowerment to draw attention to
so-called voter suppression and I do I
do to support gay marriage which proves
same sex couples can get just as fat as
heterose
but what's worse the child exploitation
or these horrible puns the company told
Fox digital they're opposed to child
labor thank you and work with a special
counsel to ensure Farm Workers are
fairly compensated and work in healthy
conditions adding that when that now
when underage workers are beaten it's
with tiny wooden sample spoons
[Laughter]
and after a 12-hour work day the kids
get their choice of toppings
anyway
in a big turnaround Ben Jerry's has
actually embraced the reputation of
child labor and came up with new flavors
to reflect that here are some of their
new flavors
Sweatshop and cream
[Laughter]
cookies there's another cookies and kids
screams
fingers to the Bone scone
[Laughter]
and my favorite death by chocolate
literally
drowned in a Vata chocolate all right
I'm going to take a different stance on
this Tyrus I don't want to defend Ben
and Jerry's but isn't child labor
underrated they get money they get
experience they probably get free ice
cream is it really that bad apparently
you can do everything to a child if they
have a job that you can't do to a woke
child in your home yes
yeah
so
I I think if it just goes back to the
whole thing it's always the progressives
that virtue signal from the highest
mountain and we always say the same
thing why are they yelling so loud from
the mountains so you won't see what's
going on at the bottom and it just seems
that it's not it's fashionable to not
get caught with child labor that's the
thing they get caught and then of course
they're doing everything they can to
make sure uh that these will that the
Farms will make sure that the kids are
not leaving the field they'll put Nets
on the outside and have guard dogs keep
little bastards inside so they can pick
but again this is what happens apple
with iPhones they had they had there was
a thing in China where people were
jumping out of Windows because of the
long hours and low pay so what did they
do they got Nets so you know yes they
did yeah since we're Googling everything
this episode Google it you would
literally I can't take this and then
fall in the net roll down to the bottom
floor and start over and then work your
way back up imagine being the company
that makes those Nets yeah you have to
do like the marketing plan yeah
show what we can do Johnny's gonna jump
from the seventh floor yes when you're
you when your workers are this small and
you just need a net to call us like it's
just
it's so we're laughing at child labor
but Emily started it so yes but yeah
Jamie uh again I'm going to you know go
I'm going to be the devil's advocate
here and I go like don't could you
what's what if the kids like you know
kids work on farms you know what a farm
is right yeah yeah you get up early you
milk some chickens yeah that's why I
went on that farmersonly.com I'm like
they milk cows
um
[Applause]
but they don't want to go out though
they get up so early the um
child labor Greg it's it's let's just
get out it's a terrible terrible thing
but I have little kids I love them but I
could use three to four hours a day
where they went to work yeah
I could use it and this might kind of
sound controversial here I know people
love their Ben and Jerry's I hate Ben
and Jerry's not a fan I know people use
it to treat depression
um
this can be one of the worst uses for do
you ever eat a lot when you're depressed
like I know people do I've done that
it's really the worst idea because
you're going like oh I'm sad I'll show
her I'll be sad and fat yes
there's also a there's a there's a
divorced one who comes half full nobody
loves it
um
[Applause]
Greg I in
fact it shows from my experience as a
divorcement I did record oh a PSA oh and
I wanted to show you guys sure go ahead
show it
[Music]
so's lessons tips from a divorced dad
when you're getting divorced make sure
you sit your kids down and tell them hey
it's not your fault okay it's your mom's
fault
[Music]
[Applause]
something there cat I learned something
there should we boycott Ben and Jerry's
except for their ice cream
[Laughter]
trick question yes
I mean it's just
child labor is kind of everywhere huh
yeah it is everybody's doing it
everyone's like I know what I'll do get
kids to work for me under horrific
conditions and no one will care
and it turns out nobody does yeah nobody
they say they care but they really don't
yeah Emily thinks it's hilarious that
children oh yeah Emily does care because
of the opposite direction he's been
waiting and waiting to be able to talk
about this is going to be Googling
tonight Google Imaging like children
working
oh look at that one's crying in the
corner yeah I just it is especially
annoying when it's a company like Ben
and Jerry's which so much of its
business model is just saying you know
other people are total pieces yeah uh
and like making kitchy little flavors
about it too but guess what even then I
still eat it yeah sometimes I can't I'm
lactose intolerant I know yeah
yeah and you'd find out the next day let
me tell you huh
because I tell you then too
Emily have you calmed down some yeah I'm
laughing at your guys's jokes not like
the concept well no you were laughing at
the concept too because actually it's
working under terrible conditions is
hilarious
well
um here's the thing so in typical
fashion no one cares they just care that
they're caught right and especially with
like you were saying the loudest voices
the top of the mountain of course they
are going to be because they're an
American Business embroiled in a supply
chain that has a lot of opacity to it
and especially this Administration which
I always have to tie everything back to
uh because remember Queen John Pierre
when the New York Times addressed this
and she was like oh gosh we have no idea
what you're talking about and this is
horrible this is exactly the people that
need to be aware that need to have their
eyes into every part of the supply chain
aren't these the people that are
supposed to be the strongest advocates
for every American out there remember
Ben and Jerry's had their comment like
but well the 16 and 17 year olds you
know they they have their extra
supervision or whatever so acknowledging
that they're sort of a special group
that deserves special attention and
special compliance they're being thrown
under the bus too remember we had all
these issues still ongoing in the
southern border right we had Attorneys
General and District Attorneys of a lot
of Southern border states mm-hmm in
counties that raise the alarm to this
Administration saying they're a teenage
and child girls who are being sexually
assaulted and have to go to the bathroom
in paper and plastic bags because you
have shoved everyone into Emergency
Shelters you would think If Everyone
Cared about kids they would have cared
then instead they took it to court and
said Eh this is nothing look the other
way the same thing is happening here
unless they're put on blast well that's
not funny what kind of job is that
though what do you do for them I'm a
professional kid worker Watcher yes I
stand in a field with a
smile and I make sure the little
bastards work and don't wander off like
that's that's not better that sounds
like good retirement work for me
you know like a crossing guard but with
more muscle yeah like a shirtless
crossing guard with a whip hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else